is political change coming to lebanon
independent and reformist candidates
make gains in parliamentary elections
while some traditional parties lose
ground but will the newcomers have the
answers to pull the country out of a
deep economic crisis this is inside
story
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm kim
vinnell
lebanon has been called a failing state
its currency is nearly worthless food
medicine and fuel are expensive and in
short supply
people are unable to rely on basic
public services like rubbish collection
and electricity to keep their lights on
many blame lebanon's politicians for
years of corruption and mismanagement a
parliamentary election on sunday was
their chance to vote for change more
than a dozen reformists and independent
candidates who emerged from protests
against the government in 2019 won seats
the iranian-backed hezbollah and its
allies lost their parliamentary majority
and some traditional parties performed
poorly the new mps face major challenges
ahead zen holo reports from beirut
many of the old faces are back but a
meaningful number of new ones made it
into lebanon's parliament which now has
a new balance of power
the iranian-backed hezbollah party and
its allies lost their majority but no
other political grouping or party can
claim victory the opposition may be
sizeable but not united
what is a first however in post-civil
war politics are the so-called
reformists who won at least 10 percent
of the seats these are candidates not
affiliated to any of the mainly
sectarian parties
we have to be
as a
king
maker
because we have not
we don't have to be in
the polarization we have to create a
bridge
those new voices will stand in the
middle of long-time enemies tensions
have already spilled onto the streets
supporters of rival parties fought on
election day local observers also
documented attacks on their teams by
supporters mostly from shia groups
hezbollah and amal many observers
witnessed so many pressures especially
in the
electoral districts of thought and
balbach hermel
by some of parties delegates and agents
and even supporters
the shia groups may have preserved the
27 seats allocated to their sect but
observers say they can no longer claim
sole representation
they did everything they can to
intimidate
voters candidates and their
representatives in the constituencies
and at the same time there's also a an
alternative shia vote so there's a shia
vote which went outside
the box and
to their opponents and that happened for
the first time in spite of their
attempts to keep it contained through
the ballot box there is no doubt change
has begun but the old divide hezbollah
and its allies on one hand and the
christian lebanese forces on the other
hand gone away
lebanon's leaders will need to work
together to agree on a new government
and elect a president in a few months
political deadlock is not unusual in
this fractured country but there is an
urgent need to adopt reforms and laws to
rescue a collapsed economy and a
polarized parliament won't make that
easy
the divide dates back to the civil war
which ended in 1990 after which power
was divided between sects but lebanon's
parliamentary democracy is in reality a
consensual democracy unanimity is needed
for the system to work and peace to be
maintained
senator al-jazeera beirut
now as zena mentioned power was divided
between the sects after the end of the
war in 1990 and that system aims to
guarantee political representation for
all of lebanon's 18 sects
parliament seats are split between
christians and muslims and allocated to
different denominations within each
religion
the president must always be a maronite
christian the prime minister a sunni
muslim and the speaker of the parliament
a shia muslim
all right let's bring in all of our
guests all joining us from beirut we
have verena el amil a positive activist
and lawyer who was running for a
parliamentary seat
jamal gossein a political commentator
and writer and talia ibrahim co-founder
and ceo of duraj.com an independent
digital media platform a very warm
welcome to the program to you all i'd
like to start with you um verena
you ran uh for parliament you didn't win
a seat in these elections what's your
take on the results generally as you
look at them how much of a shift is this
really for lebanese politics
um hello and thank you for having me
today
um i think over at if as an overall view
i think what happened um
in these elections was historic
uh for the first time we were able to
break the monopole of the ruling class
of the traditional political parties
and to bring um the
17th of october uprising to the
parliament and now we feel that the
parliament is really
from the people to the people so i think
uh it's it's not negligible what's hap
what has happened
all right i'd like to cross over to you
alia ibrahim um do you agree with that
assessment i mean the hezbollah led
block lost its parliamentary majority
but they still hezbollah and amal still
retained the same number of seats so
what does that actually say to you
uh well i would very much agree with
miss
you heard from from the candidate who
has lost in those elections and still
considered them historic and indeed what
has happened was uh for
for at least protesters for
demonstrators who in 2019 took the
streets was in every way a big win for
the lebanese uh
for the lebanese
opposition if we if we may say the
people
who have been demonstrating against the
political elite for the last uh two
three years and we've seen it across the
country from the extreme northern
extreme south we've seen for the first
time in three and thirty years uh two
seats uh in south lebanon being lost
from the jeopardy of hezbollah
we have seen the loss of traditional
faces in the lebanese in the lebanese
politics representing pretty much the
syrian regime you're talking and and
again across the country from from zach
uh with mr eddie firstly to the shuffle
understand
in terms of losing the majority the vast
majority that could allow uh
really imposing politics inside
parliament this has been lost even if
you look at the mathematics in terms of
the legitimacy also the big loss of the
fpm the free patriotic movement at the
level of being the legitimate and the
legitimate
biggest representative of the christian
voters this has also changed because in
numbers and in representation so across
the board uh we can easily say that this
was a best case scenario for the
lebanese uh
the lebanese who are outside the
political establishment in lebanon and
it is indeed i would very much agree it
is a historic uh historic uh achievement
inside the parliament you mentioned the
the fpm for our international audience
that is the free patriotic movement um
the party of uh president michelle
uh which was the biggest christian block
is no longer um i'd like to pass over to
you jamal got in what do you make of the
results is this actually indicative of a
major shift is hezbollah really losing
support
uh absolutely not this is uh i mean i
don't agree that uh
it went pretty much as expected there
was an expected uh loss uh that was
going to come to the ruling majority the
previous ruling majority
in favor of uh
emerging forces the thing is that
we still don't know where the division
lies right now and who actually may have
a majority i think we do have a centrist
block between the former leading
majority and the former
part of government that were in the
unity government that decided to
play the role of opposition
and uh right now we might see a
different uh electoral map altogether
like it's not two solid blocks but
rather maybe a
two
blocks and a swing block in the middle
uh that is composed of uh
old uh
veteran politicians uh like uh the for
the speaker of the house and uh walid
blood the leader of the progressive uh
socialist movement who have known to
play swing roles in the history of
lebanon and now they can actually have a
bigger say because they can play in the
middle and
swing one way or the other depending on
the issue and i think this is what we're
looking at right now more than a a
a complete shift in in the political
power there's just a complete it's just
a shift in the makeup of uh
of the coalitions that will be
in parliament okay uh i'd like to
prospect you verena el emil um obviously
as we've been saying one of the biggest
things to come from these elections uh
the election of of new independence so
the so-called reformists looking to
shake things up can they really make
big changes given the rigidity of the
entire
system
i think since there is
more than 10 mps now
they are able to present an appeal um in
front of the con
of the consistent constitution
uh however i think uh what's good about
the mps that are now in parliament is
that um they are from grassroots uh from
the movement from the streets uh from
the heart of the 17th of october
uprising um this means that there will
still be pressure on the streets um this
means there will be the
um some sort of cooperation with them
um this means that uh we will all uh
still support them and try um
to help this means that we will still
put more pressures
uh more pressure whether on the streets
whether
in the syndicates whether in the
universities um so i think yeah it's um
it's if we see it from a holistic
approach i think there's a lot uh to be
done alia ibrahim can independents
actually work together as a block how
much unity is there
i think this is this is a very important
point i think what we're about to see
and
this is of course
uh taking into consideration that no
violence is used by the government or by
uh by hezbollah which we have seen in
previous in previous uh
episodes if it's left to life inside
parliament dynamics are going to change
what we have seen over the last more
than 15 years was polarization within
parliament and just blocking the
political life there was no political
life in lebanon there was no what virena
was mentioning this idea of presenting
laws that are very important to the
lebanese people what's very important to
the lebanese to the average lebanese
person right now what this election have
shown us is that the lebanese care
mostly about their lives about the
economy about having electricity about
having jobs about having an income today
you're talking about a country where 80
percent of the population is on the
poverty line this is what people care
about and what we are seeing we are
seeing people who are coming
till now you look at the block of 17
people the fact that they their sects
are not important how representative
they are of the different regions in
lebanon of the different sect is not
important what's important is that they
came from uh october 19 and from october
17 and that they were not even allowed
to walk inside that parliament there is
a member of parliament today who was who
had a bullet in his heart
next to his heart while trying to get
and protects night protest next to
parliament and now he is a legislator
inside parliament we should expect that
the change of dynamics within the
legislative life in lebanon again
pending that it's left to be any
political lies among those people there
are some who come with extremely
sophisticated backgrounds in
environmental issues and economic issues
and i'm pretty sure their input will not
be will not be small if they're allowed
to block how important it is that they
agree on all matters i really don't
think it's very important that they they
are represented as a block on all
matters okay if this is yeah i just want
to ask you could diverge on
priorities i hear you i want to i want
to um
i want to push into something that you
raised as you said 80 of the population
according to the un
um lives in some form of poverty if
you're looking at i think it's 20
different indicators things like access
to sanitation health
school attendance as well as things like
income i mean that's that's phenomenal
if the population um you know is
obviously struggling so much why were
there not more people voting for
reformists why were there not more
people voting for independence
because this was a sanctioned uh
election as well the boycotting in some
areas was to tell the political
establishment we're not going to give
you a vote of confidence what we have
seen is as a decrease in the no in the
overall
but it was an increase and some people
would have voted before and who voted
for the for that for change a lot of
people don't have the luxury to go in in
certain areas and vote like they would
want to vote the turnout that was
smaller in a lot of places was just a
vote of no confidence uh uh
and a lot of people actually voted
this is a vote of no confidence in the
political establishment
the newcomers are very fresh they are
going to be tested a lot of people did
not know them a lot of they didn't they
didn't even have great access to the
media they are not very well known so
this is this is really understandable
plus there was so much that was done to
demotivate people to to terrorize people
in a lot of cases not to
when they are not to be going to vote
against uh against the different uh
establishment uh
uh lists across the country
and of course there was the call from
not to boycott the elections but which
again played a role in certain areas
like
like north lebanon like tripoli so there
was a lot that contributed to the low
turnout but again we have to take into
consideration that this was paralleled
by a higher turnout in diaspora that
made a difference at the level of the of
the final results because the diaspora
mostly voted for change okay jamal
grossin i'd like to cross over to you
what message if any do you think that
the voting in of of this number of
reformist candidates what what message
do you think that sends to the political
establishment
again we must be looking at different
numbers because if you look at the
numbers in light of what was happening
in lebanon and
and we see that
there is a strong affirming
vote for some of the powers like uh
uh the
hezbollah who got more votes than last
time uh for the fpm they were uh
predicted uh that they would
it would be the demise of them they lost
a couple of votes so the voting turned
out what we saw like the new block that
came in basically came and inherited
uh the block that uh basically withdrew
and boycotted the election and we're
talking about the future movement uh led
by former prime minister sadhari
and these people who we call or some
people are calling reformists uh is also
assuming that they claim to be
reformists uh we uh you're talking about
poverty and about the economic issues we
haven't yet to hear any different
economic proposals that might come from
these uh some of these people actually
of the new candidates in parliament
they're actually
carry the voice of the imf and and the
bankers and they're pushing for
the privatization of state assets in
order to recover the losses of the ponzi
scheme that the banks uh have so this is
a
this is a very dangerous thing that the
lebanese people might be
must be aware of because you have the
illusion of new faces but it's going to
be the same economic policies that led
to this economic collapse they're
basically
neo-hariris and i'm not talking about
everybody here of course i'm talking
about uh alia mentioned that there are
the people didn't get attention in the
media one of the candidates that won and
one big uh mark though was the host of a
prime time tv show to create
an alternative i don't know if what more
attention in the media can a platform
get and these a lot of the candidates
that run in his circle are pro imf
policies they're pro privatization and
they're
not any different economically with
their policies than what got lebanon to
this disaster that they're in it doesn't
sound like you have any hope of any
change um mr gossen i mean whoever is
the new prime minister will have to work
with the international monetary fund to
try and get lebanon out of this economic
crisis so do do you do you have any hope
for the future if if what has gotten the
country to this point it sounds like you
don't expect anything to change
well this is the whole uh i mean raising
the hopes uh is dangerous because the
problem in lebanon is not it's not
technical it's not a matter of a minor
legislation here or a law here or policy
here it's actually structural this
country has been uh in trouble or and on
weak grounds since
its inception 100 years ago we've always
had collapses wars and it's always seems
to spiral down into this area because
there is a structure a structural issue
you cannot have this country built on
this confessional system even if you
look at the elections right now you see
that there is under representation of uh
people from certain areas and certain
religions uh compared to others and this
has to do with uh their social class
with their whether their old money or
old establishment or not so the division
is elsewhere it's not about uh
so this and this is structural this
could not be resolved by legislation
lebanon needs a new constitution and use
a new uh
social contract in order for it to solve
its problems i can see um ali ibrahim
you want to jump in what did you want to
add there
yes it's just really a very minor point
that is very important portraying the
newcomers i agree that they are
newcomers that they need time to test
them i also believe that they need to
get the time to be tested today we are
hearing what have they done the dollar
has has jumped already these people have
have not even walked inside parliament
and people are asking for change that is
going to happen so quickly we need to
give them time but to say that they
represent uh the bankers again let's
look at the list let's look at the
candidates that were running on the list
of the establishment in south lebanon uh
mr marwan
who i would believe is a representative
of that he's a bank owner who has played
a role in transferring money of peps
outside lebanon when the depositors were
losing their money he was running on the
list of hezbollah and it does not get
more uh bankers oriented than that and
he lost to somebody who does not come
from a rich family who does not come
from
the imf circuits at all on the country
what we are looking at there is all this
conversation that needs to be had about
how to save the economic situation in
lebanon and we have to look i personally
am absolutely not
for selling government government assets
or even then doing anything with them
unless we have uh
functioning political lives this is a
government this is a system that has
already taken us into bankruptcy it
cannot itself figure out the economic
solutions we would lose whatever is left
but to say that the newcomers are the
ones flirting with the ims is is simply
uh not correct all the data shows
exactly the opposite of that we are
coming almost to the end of the program
we've got a few minutes left uh verena
el amil if we look at the road ahead um
the current parliament expires the 22nd
of may then there has to be a new
speaker elected then the president calls
for binding consultations to choose the
prime minister who will form a
government how do you foresee this
process how do you think it's going to
go
i think um
the challenge here is um i think for the
first time
um the ruling class the traditional
political political parties
don't have as i was saying before uh the
the monopoly
of representation i think they are
afraid because something has changed a
fundamental change i agree with
mr jamal was saying that
i think we need
a fundamental systematic change but i
think sometimes this kind of change can
be met through the legislations um and i
think
if we continue to present some laws if
we continue to lobby from the inside
from the outside to put pressure on the
streets to put pressure everywhere i
think yes we can
we can meet the change that we want
as for the next road map um i think um
it's important um the next i think
what's what's mostly important is um
the economic economic
crisis and the way out and i think
what's most important is not to sell um
the
the the states uh
the state's resources so i think that's
the most important thing in the uh
coming phase thank you very much uh for
your time
verena el amir thank you to all our
guests jamal gottin and alia ibrahim and
thank you two for watching you can see
the program again anytime by visiting
our website al jazeera.com and for
further discussion go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com
aj inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from me kim vanell and
the whole team here in doha bye for now
[Music]
you